Well start with the house class.
To begin with, the house class will
have three properties an address,
represented as an MLS.
sting.
A bowl, indicating whether
the House has a hot tub or not.
And an int,
representing the number of bedrooms.
In the diagram here, I've depicted
objects, outlined in orange.
>> To write our house class first we're
going to create a command line project.
We'll be making a lot of these
throughout the course so
do take the time to click
through these steps on your own.
Under file click New, and
then Project instead of an iOS
app this time choose OS X application
and then command line tool.
And we'll call this house, and
make sure Objective C is
the language that's chosen.
With a command line tool, we can
focus on the code and not worry so
much about the UI.
To add the files for
the house class to the project,
control click on the house folder just
like you would any other Xcode project.
Go down to a new file.
Choose OS10 as your source and
then coco class.
And again, we'll call the class house.
Now, in the project navigator on the
left you should see the files house.age
and house.m.
In Objective C every class is associated
with two files, a header file and
an implementation file.
The header file represents the public
interface and the implementation file
holds method implementations as well as
any properties we'd like to be private.
Open up the house.h file and
you'll see that the house class
descends from the class in this object.
All objective C classes
descend from this class.
The class has been declared for
us using at @interface
the name of the class colon and
then the name of the superclass.
Let's go ahead and
declare our properties.
For now, we'll do that in the header
file which means they'll be public and
accessible outside the class.
To do that I type at sign property
nonatomic then the class that
the property belongs to which
in this case is an NSString, and
asterisk to indicate
that this is a pointer.
And then,
the name of the property address and
of course top it all
off with a semi-colon.
We'll add number of bedrooms,
and since a number of bedrooms is
a primitive type, an int,
we don't use a pointer.
And the same goes for
the BOOL, hasHotTub.